Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander peoples should be aware that this episode contains the names of people who have passed away. The families of Cindy and Mona Lisa Smith have given case file permission to wear this content.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目简介。原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民应注意，本期节目包含已故人员的姓名。辛迪和莫娜·丽莎·史密斯（Cindy and Mona Lisa Smith）的家属已授权案件档案使用本内容。
Cousins Jacinta Rose and Mona Lisa Smith had been inseparable since childhood. The two girls were just one year apart in age and grew up close to one another in the small town of Burke, located in central northern New South Wales. Jacinta, who was the younger of the two, was better known by her nickname of Cindy. She was born on October 23, 1972 and was the youngest of seven children, with four brothers and two sisters. She lived with her mother Iona Dawn Smith and her siblings in a house on the east side of town.
表亲杰辛塔·罗斯和莫娜·丽莎·史密斯（Jacinta Rose and Mona Lisa Smith）自童年起就形影不离。两个女孩年龄仅相差一岁，在新南威尔士州中北部的小镇伯克（Burke）附近长大。杰辛塔是两人中较小的一个，人们更熟悉她的昵称辛迪。她出生于1972年10月23日，是七个孩子中最小的一个，有四个哥哥和两个姐姐。她与母亲艾奥娜·道恩·史密斯（Iona Dawn Smith）以及兄弟姐妹们住在镇东边的一所房子里。
She was often looked after by her brother Lloyd, who was seven years her senior. Mona Lisa's family resided on an Aboriginal reserve named the Alice Edwards Village, which was located about two and a half kilometres west of Burke. And by locals as the reserve, the Alice Edwards Village consisted of 20 cottages, which were run down and overcrowded. It was entirely populated by Indigenous Australians from two families, the Edwards and the Smiths. Siblings, cousins and other extended family members lived side by side, and the close community provided a sense of safety and belonging to its residents.
她经常由比她大七岁的哥哥劳埃德（Lloyd）照顾。莫娜·丽莎的家人居住在一个名为爱丽丝爱德华兹村（Alice Edwards Village）的原住民保留地，该保留地位于伯克以西约两公里半处。当地人简称其为保留地，爱丽丝爱德华兹村由20栋破旧且过度拥挤的小屋组成。这里完全居住着来自两个家族的澳大利亚原住民，即爱德华兹家族和史密斯家族。兄弟姐妹、表亲和其他大家庭成员毗邻而居，这个紧密的社区为居民带来了一种安全感和归属感。
Mona Lisa was born on November 29, 1971, to parents June Smith and Dougie Shillingsworth. On the night she was born, her father had walked to Burke Hospital to visit June and their newborn, singing Nat King Cole's song Mona Lisa the entire way. This led the couple to name their baby girl after the famous song. They also had another daughter Fiona and four sons. Dougie held big dreams for all of his children, hoping that they would have good jobs and lead successful lives. The close knit family spent their evenings together dancing and singing, but when Mona
莫娜·丽莎于1971年11月29日出生，父母是琼·史密斯（June Smith）和道基·希林斯沃思（Dougie Shillingsworth）。在她出生的当晚，她的父亲步行前往伯克医院看望琼和他们的新生儿，一路上都在唱着纳特·金·科尔（Nat King Cole）的歌曲《莫娜·丽莎》（Mona Lisa）。这使得这对夫妇用这首著名的歌曲来给他们的女婴命名。他们还育有另一个女儿菲奥娜和四个儿子。道基对他的所有孩子抱有很大的期望，希望他们能有好工作并过上成功的生活。这个紧密的家庭在晚上一起唱歌跳舞，但当莫娜
Lisa was just six years old, Dougie suffered a heart attack and passed away. Cindy and Mona attended primary school together before enrolling at the same high school. They were both happy-go-lucky, popular, kind and well-liked. Cindy was the nurturing type, taking on babysitting duties and caring for her younger cousins when needed. Mona also babysat for her cousins and was sporty, playing regularly in a netball team. When Cindy was in her early teens she left high school and Mona followed suit at the end of 1987 when she was 16 years old.
丽莎只有六岁时，道基突发心脏病去世了。辛迪和莫纳一起上小学，后来又进入同一所高中就读。她们俩都生性乐天、受欢迎、善良且讨人喜欢。辛迪很有母性，经常承担照顾孩子的工作，在需要时照顾年幼的表亲。莫娜也帮表亲带孩子，并且很有运动天赋，经常打无板篮球（netball）队。辛迪十几岁出头时退学了，莫娜也在1987年底16岁时跟随她的脚步退了学。
Cindy, who was now 15, often travelled the short distance to the reserve to spend time with Mona and her family. The two girls occasionally got up to mischief together, but they were well-behaved and widely regarded as good kids. Because there wasn't a lot to do in Burke, which was a remote outback town, they would spend their time hanging out with friends, visiting parks and swimming and fishing at the nearby Darling River. On Saturday, December 5, 1987, Cindy and Mona spent the day together and accompanied one
现年15岁的辛迪经常短途跋涉前往保留地，与莫娜及其家人共度时光。这两个女孩偶尔会一起调皮捣蛋，但她们表现良好，被普遍认为是好孩子。由于地处偏远的内陆小镇伯克没有什么娱乐活动，她们会把时间花在和朋友闲逛、逛公园，以及在附近的达令河（Darling River）游泳和钓鱼上。1987年12月5日星期六，辛迪和莫娜一起度过了这一天，并陪同她们的
of their aunties to a nearby park. By the time evening fell, the two of them had decided to go into town. Burke was a small town with a population of just 3,400 people. It was originally home to the Namba people, but when white settlers arrived in the area during the mid-1800s, these traditional landholders were dispossessed. Like all indigenous people across Australia, the Namba people battled a loss of land and culture, were hit hard by European disease, and experienced conflict with colonists. By the late 19th century, their population had dwindled.
一位阿姨去了附近的公园。到了傍晚时分，两人决定进城。伯克是一个小镇，人口仅有3,400人。这里最初是纳姆巴（Namba）人的家园，但在19世纪中期白人定居者来到该地区时，这些传统的土地所有者被剥夺了土地。像澳大利亚各地的所有原住民一样，纳姆巴人与土地和文化的丧失作斗争，饱受欧洲疾病的重创，并与殖民者发生了冲突。到19世纪末，他们的人口已经锐减。
While some continued to live a traditional lifestyle in the region surrounding Burke, others found employment on nearby cattle stations. In the 1940s, Burke's indigenous population grew again when displaced people from other regions arrived. The majority of these indigenous settlers were Wonka Mara people from the far northwest of New South Wales, and they included some of Cindy Smith's relatives. By the late 1980s, Burke was home to a mix of indigenous and white Australians, as well as itinerant workers who worked on the cotton farms in the surrounding area.
虽然有些人继续在伯克周边地区过着传统的生活方式，但另一些人则在附近的养牛场找到了工作。20世纪40年代，随着来自其他地区的流离失所者到达，伯克原住民人口再次增长。这些原住民定居者的大多数是来自新南威尔士州远西北部的翁卡马拉（Wonka Mara）人，其中包含辛迪·史密斯的一些亲戚。到20世纪80年代末，伯克居住着原住民和白人澳大利亚人，以及在周边地区棉花农场工作的流动工人。
Aboriginal people in the community were often subjected to racism and discrimination, and the town had a high crime rate, with significant levels of alcohol and drug abuse. Despite this, Mona Smith's sister Fiona told Casephile it generally felt like a safe place to live. Neither Cindy nor Mona had ever travelled far from their hometown. The furthest away they had been was the town of Angonia, located 97km north of Burke. Both girls were well known in their community and had a number of friends and acquaintances around town.
社区中的原住民经常遭受种族主义和歧视，该镇的犯罪率很高，酒精和药物滥用现象严重。尽管如此，莫娜·史密斯的姐姐菲奥娜向Casephile透露，这里总体上感觉是一个安全的生活场所。辛迪和莫娜从未去过离家乡很远的地方。她们去过最远的地方是距离伯克以北97公里的安戈尼亚（Angonia）镇。两个女孩在当地都很有名，在城里有很多朋友和熟人。
On the evening of Saturday, December 5, they headed into Burke at around 7.30pm. As it was early summer, there was still daylight when they arrived. Cindy, who was the smaller of the two, was wearing a blue, yellow and white striped t-shirt, black track suit pants, and blue and white runners. Mona was dressed in black track suit pants and navy blue hoodie with the words Perisher Valley on the hood, white and blue football socks with red trim, and a pair of runners. The two girls went to the home of Mona's cousin, 18-year-old Daniel Booth, then hung out near his house for a little while.
12月5日星期六晚上，她们在大约晚上7点30分前往伯克。由于正值初夏，她们到达时天色依然亮着。体型较小的辛迪穿着一件蓝、黄、白相间的T恤、黑色运动裤以及蓝白相间的运动鞋。莫娜穿着黑色运动裤连帽衫，连帽上印有“佩里瑟谷”（Perisher Valley）字样，还有带有红色滚边的白蓝相间足球袜以及一双运动鞋。两个女孩来到了莫娜的表弟、18岁的丹尼尔·布思（Daniel Booth）的家，随后在他的房子附近闲逛了一会儿。
At around 9pm, they were seen walking back to the reserve. At 4am on the morning of Sunday, December 6, three farm workers and their wives left a farm north of Burke to drive to a small town over the state border in southern Queensland. It was still dark outside when the six of them piled into two separate four-wheel drives and made their way to the nearby Mitchell Highway, which is a key road link connecting New South Wales with Queensland. Locals refer to the stretch of highway between Burke and the nearest town to the north, Angonia, as the Angonia Road.
晚上9点左右，人们看到她们步行返回保留地。12月6日星期日凌晨4点，三名农场工人和他们的妻子离开伯克以北的一家农场，开车前往昆士兰州南部跨州边界的一个小镇。外面依然漆黑一片，这六人挤进两辆不同的四驱车，驶向附近的米切尔高速公路（Mitchell Highway），这是连接新南威尔士州与昆士兰州的关键公路干线。当地人将伯克和北部最近的小镇安戈尼亚之间的这段高速公路称为安戈尼亚路（Angonia Road）。
The rural two-lane roadway measures about six metres wide and is bordered by red dirt and sparse patches of scrub, with taller trees growing slightly further away. After travelling for about 30 minutes along Angonia Road, the driver of the first vehicle, Farm Foreman Tex Johnson, spotted a horrific scene. A white 1985 Toyota Hilux Ute sat wrecked by the side of the highway, with its driver's side roofs smashed in and its windscreen lying on the ground. Nearby, along the shoulder of the road, was a body lying face down. Tex told his wife Adele to stay in the car while he got out to inspect the crash.
这条乡村双车道公路宽约六米，两旁是红土和稀疏的灌木丛，稍远处长着更高的树木。沿着安戈尼亚路行驶了大约30分钟后，第一辆车的司机、农场领班特克斯·约翰逊（Tex Johnson）发现了一个可怕的场景。一辆白色1985年丰田海拉克斯（Toyota Hilux）皮卡车在高速公路边撞毁，驾驶员一侧的车顶被压扁，挡风玻璃落在地上。在附近的路肩上，躺着一具面朝下的尸体。特克斯告诉他的妻子阿黛尔（Adele）留在车里，而他则下车检查车祸情况。
He approached the body and saw that it belonged to an adolescent Aboriginal girl. She had seemingly been tossed from the car, then rolled into a hollow dirt area by the side of the road that functioned as a drain. The girl had sustained severe injuries and was deceased. She was wearing black Traxupants and a navy blue hoodie, the same outfit that Burke teen Mona Lisa Smith had been wearing the previous day. Adele then called out of the car window that she could see two more bodies near some scrub by the side of the road.
他走近尸体，发现死者是一名未成年原住民女孩。她似乎被抛出了车外，然后滚进了路边作为一个排水沟的凹陷泥地里。女孩受了重伤，已经死亡。她穿着黑色运动裤和海军蓝连帽衫，这与伯克少女莫娜·丽莎·史密斯前一天穿的衣服一模一样。随后，阿黛尔从车窗大喊，称她看到路边的一些灌木丛附近还有两具尸体。
By this time, the second four-wheel drive had arrived and pulled over. It was being driven by Tex's brother Shane Batty, who had also gotten out to survey the scene. Tex approached the bodies that his wife had noticed. They were lying alongside one another on a sheet of tarpaulin that looked as though it had been neatly laid out on the ground. One of the bodies was that of an Aboriginal girl dressed in the clothes of Mona Lisa's cousin Cindy, a blue, yellow and white striped t-shirt and black Traxupants.
此时，第二辆四驱车已经到达并停了下来。开车的正是特克斯的弟弟肖恩·巴蒂（Shane Batty），他也下车查看现场。特克斯走向他妻子注意到的尸体。它们并排躺在一张防水油布上，看起来像是被整整齐齐地铺在地上。其中一具尸体是一个原住民女孩，穿着莫娜丽莎的表妹辛迪的衣服，即一件蓝、黄、白相间的T恤和黑色运动裤。
While her t-shirt covered her torso and upper legs, her pants and underwear were both down around her ankles. A middle-aged white man lay next to her, his left arm draped across her chest. On one corner of the tarpaulin, sat a half-empty bottle of beer. Shane checked the girl for a pulse, but found none. As the two brothers assessed the scene, the man lying alongside the girl stirred and came to, appearing groggy but uninjured. Shane informed the man that the two teenage girls in his company were both deceased and
虽然她的T恤盖住了躯干和上腿，但她的裤子和内衣都退到了脚踝周围。一个中年白人男子躺在她旁边，他的左臂搭在她的胸前。在防水油布的一个角落里，放着一瓶喝了一半的啤酒。肖恩检查了女孩的脉搏，但没有发现。正当两兄弟评估现场时，躺在女孩身边的那个男子苏醒过来，显得迷迷糊糊但没有受伤。肖恩告诉这名男子，他同伴中的两个十几岁女孩都已经去世，并
referred to them using a racial slur. The man looked up and insisted Shane was wrong, explaining that the two girls had too much to drink. He then lay down again, resuming his original position next to the deceased teenager. Shane got back into his vehicle and drove to Angonia to report the crash, while everyone else stayed behind at the scene. Tex again attempted to inform the man that the girls were both dead, but he became abusive in response, telling Tex to fuck off.
用带有种族歧视的词语称呼她们。那名男子抬头坚称肖恩搞错了，并解释说这两个女孩喝了太多酒。随后他又躺了下去，恢复了挨着已故少女的原始姿势。肖恩回到车里，开车去安戈尼亚报告车祸，而其他人则留在现场。特克斯再次试图告知这名男子两个女孩都死了，但他却恶语相向，让特克斯滚开。
Eventually, Tex, the other farmhand, and the women decided to follow Shane to Angonia, which was 34km north of their location. It was 5am when Shane arrived at Angonia and alerted the police. Constables Kevin Harper and Ken McKenzie set out immediately, arriving at the scene of the crash at 5.45. They saw Mona Lisa Smith's body lying by the shoulder of the roadway and a man standing by the damaged Toyota Hilux near the Tarpaulin where Cindy Smith lay. The officers noticed that Cindy's t-shirt was up around her neck, revealing her breasts,
最终，特克斯、另一名农场工人和女人们决定跟随肖恩前往位于他们所在地以北34公里的安戈尼亚。肖恩于凌晨5点到达安戈尼亚并报警。警员凯文·哈珀（Kevin Harper）和肯·麦肯齐（Ken McKenzie）立即出发，于5点45分到达车祸现场。他们看到莫娜·丽莎·史密斯的尸体躺在路肩旁，一名男子站在受损的丰田海拉克斯旁，靠近辛迪·史密斯躺着的防水油布。警员们注意到辛迪的T恤卷到了脖子周围，露出了她的胸部，
and her left leg was bent at the knee, lying at an angle to the rest of her body and exposing her genitals. Upon approaching the man, the two officers saw he appeared to be heavily intoxicated and confused. He was dirty and disheveled, dressed in a khaki shirt, matching pants and work boots. His speech was slurred as he told the two policemen that he had been in the crash and was driving the ute at the time. Constable McKenzie went to cover Cindy's naked body with an excess portion of the tarp,
她的左腿在膝盖处弯曲，与身体其余部分成一定角度，暴露出她的生殖器。走近该男子时，两名警员发现他看起来神志不清且严重醉酒。他浑身肮脏、衣衫褴褛，穿着卡其色衬衫、同色长裤和工作靴。他说话含糊不清，告诉两名警察他遭遇了车祸，出事时正是他开着这辆皮卡。麦肯齐警员试图用防水油布多余的部分盖住辛迪赤裸的尸体，
and as he did so, the man asked, they're only asleep aren't they? Constable McKenzie replied angrily that both girls were dead, but the man continued to insist they were merely sleeping. The officers asked the man to explain what had happened and where he had been travelling to. He responded that he didn't know what occurred, but he had been driving from Burke to North Burke, which was about a 10 kilometer distance. He was surprised to learn he was actually 63 kilometers from Burke.
正当他这么做时，那名男子问：“她们只是睡着了，对吧？”麦肯齐警员愤怒地回答说两个女孩都死了，但该男子仍然坚称她们只是在睡觉。警员要求该男子解释发生了什么事以及他原本要去哪里。他回答说他不知道发生了什么，但他当时正从伯克开往北伯克，那里的距离大约是10公里。得知自己实际上距离伯克有63公里时，他感到很惊讶。
Suddenly, he pointed at Mona and told the officers, quote, she was driving. The man was identified as 40-year-old Alexander Grant, who explained that he'd been drinking the previous day at several pubs in Burke. He didn't know the names of the two girls, but they had asked him for a lift to the North Burke Hotel. To the officers, it appeared that Grant was still very intoxicated. His eyes were bloodshot, his speech was occasionally incoherent, and his breath smelled strongly of alcohol.
突然，他指着莫娜对警员说：“原话是，是她在开车。”该男子被确认身份为40岁的亚历山大·格兰特（Alexander Grant），他解释说前一天他在伯克的几家酒吧喝过酒。他不认识这两个女孩，但她们曾向他搭车去北伯克酒店。在警员看来，格兰特似乎仍然处于高度醉酒状态。他的眼睛布满血丝，说话有时语无伦次，呼吸中散发着浓烈的酒气。
At times, he seemed to struggle to stand upright and supported himself by leaning against the police car. Constable McKenzie inspected the man's Toyota Hilux and noted there was extensive damage to the roof, the front passenger panels, and the driver's side. All of the tires appeared to be in good condition, but the rear passenger side rim was buckled. The windscreen was lying on the ground, as were a number of tools and pieces of equipment. It was a manual vehicle and only had two doors, both of which were jammed shut. Constable McKenzie reached through the driver's window to check the steering wheel and saw
有时，他似乎难以站直，靠着警车支撑身体。麦肯齐警员检查了这名男子的丰田海拉克斯，发现车顶、前乘客侧车身面板以及驾驶员一侧均有严重损坏。所有的轮胎看起来状况良好，但后乘客侧的车轮毂发生了弯曲。挡风玻璃躺在地上，还有许多工具和设备。这是一辆手动挡汽车，只有两个门，两个车门都卡死无法打开。麦肯齐警员通过驾驶员车窗查看方向盘，发现
that the keys were missing from the ignition. The road itself was about six metres wide, and the sealed bitumen was in good condition, with wide table drain on both sides of the road. The speed limit on the highway was 100 kilometres per hour. At 6am, two ambulances arrived from Burke. Grants' vital signs were checked and found to be normal. When Grant overheard Constable McKenzie telling an ambulance officer that he had been driving the vehicle, he shouted out, no, she was the driver, and again pointed at Mona.
钥匙从点火开关上拔掉了。道路本身大约六米宽，密封的沥青路面状况良好，道路两侧有宽阔的边沟。高速公路的限速是每小时100公里。早上6点，两辆救护车从伯克赶到。检查了格兰特的生命体征，发现一切正常。当格兰特无意中听到麦肯齐警员告诉救护人员他一直在开车时，他大喊道：“不，她是司机，”并再次指向莫娜。
The paramedics confirmed that both girls were deceased, before transferring Grant to hospital for a more thorough examination. As he was being driven to the hospital, Grant asked if they could stop in at the caravan park where he lived so he could tell his wife what had happened, but the ambulance officer refused. A second ambulance transported the girls' bodies to Burke to be autopsyed, while a tow truck took the Toyota Hilux to Angonia police station. By 7.30am, a detective from Burke named Peter Esmond had arrived at the crash site.
医护人员确认两个女孩均已死亡，随后将格兰特送往医院进行更彻底的检查。在被送往医院的途中，格兰特询问是否可以在他居住的房车公园停一下，以便他将发生的事情告诉妻子，但救护人员拒绝了。第二辆救护车将女孩们的尸体运往伯克进行尸检，而一辆拖车则将丰田海拉克斯拖到了安戈尼亚警察局。到早上7点30分，一名来自伯克的名叫彼得·伊斯蒙德（Peter Esmond）的侦探到达了车祸现场。
Detective Esmond examined the scene and noticed a second empty bottle of beer in addition to the one on the tarpaulin that was half-consumed, as well as an almost empty bottle of rum inside the vehicle. Constable McKenzie drew a detailed sketch of the site, including measurements of the road, the proximity of the bodies to the vehicle, and skid marks left by the tyres. He later surmised how the crash had unfolded in a statement. Quote, As the vehicle travelled along a straight portion of roadway about 260 metres off the Burke 63 kilometre marker peg, the driver has lost
伊斯蒙德侦探检查了现场，除了防水油布上那瓶喝了一半的啤酒外，还发现了第二瓶空啤酒，车内还有一瓶几乎见底的朗姆酒。麦肯齐警员绘制了现场的详细草图，包括道路尺寸、尸体与车辆的距离以及轮胎留下的刹车痕迹。他后来在一份声明中推测了车祸是如何发生的：“原文：当车辆沿着距离伯克63公里路标约260米的一段笔直路段行驶时，司机失去了
control of the vehicle, and the vehicle has left the left side of the roadway and travelled with the nearside wheels in the gravel for a distance of approximately 32 metres. The vehicle has then veered to the centre of the roadway in a curve for a distance of about 36 metres before veering to the nearside of the roadway again. The vehicle has again left the roadway on the western side and travelled a distance of 35 metres in a left-hand broadside and then rolled over. The vehicle rolled once and came to rest on its wheels again near the side of the bitumen and then rolled back down the slight embankment of the roadway shoulder and stopped on the
对车辆的控制，车辆驶离道路左侧，近侧车轮在碎石路面上行驶了大约32米距离。随后车辆在弯道中向道路中央偏离了约36米距离，然后再次向道路近侧偏离。车辆再次从西侧驶离道路，以左侧横向滑行了35米距离，然后翻车。车辆翻转了一次，再次停在沥青路面边缘的车轮上，接着又滚回道路路肩的轻微斜坡，停在
edge of the light scrub. The vehicle is expected to be a total write-off as a result of the accident. Alexander Grant was examined at the hospital where it was confirmed that he had only sustained a knock to his head and grazed elbows. Testing revealed he had a blood alcohol content of 0.159, more than three times the legal limit in Australia. Grant was 40 years old and had grown up in Hamilton, New Zealand. After finishing school, he took up intermittent work on farms and construction sites.
低矮灌木丛的边缘。由于此次事故，该车辆预计将彻底报废。”亚历山大·格兰特在医院接受了检查，确认他仅头部受到撞击且手肘擦伤。测试显示他的血液酒精浓度为0.159，超过了澳大利亚法定限制的三倍多。格兰特40岁，在新西兰汉密尔顿（Hamilton）长大。毕业后，他在农场和建筑工地断断续续地工作。
By 1970, he'd been married and divorced and he moved to Australia in 1977 at the age of 30. He had dark hair that he combed back over his head and a thin face and build and was five feet ten inches tall. For a time, Grant resided in the northern New South Wales town of Moree where he worked various jobs in excavation. By the early 1980s, he'd had a number of encounters with the police due to his pattern of drinking and driving.
到1970年，他已经结婚并离婚，并于1977年以30岁的年龄移居澳大利亚。他有着向后梳理的黑发，面容消瘦、身材匀称，身高五英尺十英寸。有一段时间，格兰特居住在新南威尔士州北部的莫里（Moree）镇，从事各种挖掘工作。到20世纪80年代初，由于他经常酒后驾车，他曾多次与警方打交道。
In late October 1980, he was picked up for drink driving and had his driver's license disqualified for three months. The following month, he was again arrested for driving while drunk and had a blood alcohol reading of more than twice the legal limit. He had a further six months added to his license disqualification, was placed on a good behaviour bond for three years and fined $1,500. Two months later, in February 1981, Grant was booked for speeding. Even though he was still disqualified from driving, the charge was dismissed after no
1980年10月下旬，他因酒后驾车被捕，驾驶执照被吊销三个月。次月，他再次因酒后驾车被捕，血液酒精读数超过法定标准的两倍。他的驾照吊销期又被延长了六个月，被处以三年内行为良好的保证（good behaviour bond），并被罚款1,500美元。两个月后的1981年2月，格兰特因超速被记过。尽管他当时仍处于驾照吊销期，但由于无法提供
concrete proof could be offered that he was exceeding the speed limit. In May 1983, Grant was arrested for driving while disqualified and was fined $800 and disqualified from driving until the end of November 1984. In mid-1987, Grant moved to Burke where he resided in a caravan park and worked as an itinerant excavator driver. At the time of the crash, he was employed at a cotton gin in North Burke where he excavated irrigation channels. Despite telling the ambulance officer that he had a wife, Grant was unmarried and owned
他超速行驶的具体确凿证据，该指控被驳回。1983年5月，格兰特因在吊销驾照期间驾驶而被捕，被罚款800美元，且驾照被吊销至1984年11月底。1987年中期，格兰特搬到伯克，住在一家房车公园里，并作为一名流动的挖掘机司机工作。车祸发生时，他在北伯克的一家轧棉厂工作，负责挖掘灌溉渠。尽管告诉救护人员他有妻子，但格兰特其实未婚，
next to nothing in terms of assets. While he was in hospital on the morning of December 6, 1987, Grant provided his first official police statement. He claimed that as he was making a phone call from a pub in Burke the previous night, the two girls had approached and asked him for a lift to North Burke. They agreed and they all piled into his ute, leaving Burke at around 11pm. Grant was in the driver's seat, Cindy was next to him in the middle and Mona, whom he identified as, quote, the bigger girl, was on the end.
名下几乎没有任何资产。1987年12月6日早上在医院时，格兰特提供了他的第一份官方警方供词。他声称，前一晚当他在伯克的一家酒吧打电话时，这两个女孩走过来要求他搭便车去北伯克。他们达成一致，全都挤进他的皮卡车里，于晚上11点左右离开伯克。格兰特坐在驾驶座上，辛迪坐在他中间旁边，他称为“原文：体型较大的女孩”的莫娜则坐在最外侧。
As they were travelling north, Grant alleged that the bigger girl asked if she could have a turn driving. He said he initially refused, but then agreed upon seeing how little traffic there was. Mona mostly stayed under the speed limit by going between 70 and 80km per hour and was a smooth, steady driver. Grant claimed that at one stage she sped up to the limit of 100, at which point he told her to slow down and grabbed the steering wheel. After she had driven for approximately 30 to 40km, they pulled over to have a drink
在他们向北行驶的过程中，格兰特声称体型较大的女孩问她是否可以轮流开车。他说自己最初拒绝了，但看到路上车流量如此稀少后便同意了。莫娜的车速基本控制在每小时70到80公里之间，没有超速，是一个平稳、镇定的司机。格兰特声称，有一次她加速到了100公里的限速，当时他告诉她减速并抓住了方向盘。在她驾驶了大约30到40公里后，他们把车停在路边喝一杯
and a cigarette. They then turned around to head back to Burke and Grant said Mona took the wheel again. Suddenly the vehicle had veered, though Grant had no idea why. He estimated that the time of the crash was either between 1am and 2am or 2am and 3am. As this meant a minimum of two hours had passed between the three of them leaving Burke and the crash taking place, there was a significant chunk of time that Grant was unable or unwilling to account for. When questioned about the alcohol he had consumed, Grant said he'd had his first drink at around
并抽支烟。然后他们掉头准备返回伯克，格兰特称莫娜再次坐到方向盘前。突然车辆偏离了方向，尽管格兰特完全不知道原因。他估计车祸发生的时间是在凌晨1点到2点之间，或者是凌晨2点到3点之间。这意味着他们离开伯克和车祸发生之间至少过去了两个小时，格兰特有一大段时间无法或不愿做出解释。当被问及他消费的酒精时，格兰特说他在前一天傍晚
5.30 or 6pm the previous day at the Carrier's Arms Hotel in Burke. He hadn't kept count, but he believed he'd drunk between 6 and 10 mt of beer, each measuring 285ml, or the equivalent of 1.1 standard drinks. His last drink had been at about 11pm or midnight, which was a bottle of beer he consumed while driving with the two girls. Grant denied drinking between the time of the crash and when the police arrived. He was released from the hospital by late morning and went to Burke police station to provide another statement to Detective Peter Resman.
5点半或6点左右在伯克的运载者武器酒店（Carrier's Arms Hotel）喝了第一杯酒。他没有细数，但他认为自己喝了6到10毫升（原文如此）的啤酒，每瓶容量为285毫升，相当于1.1个标准饮酒量。他的最后一杯酒大约在晚上11点或午夜喝下，那是他在载着两个女孩开车时喝的一瓶啤酒。格兰特否认在车祸发生到警察到达之间饮酒。他于深夜前从医院出院，并前往伯克警察局向彼得·雷斯曼（Peter Resman）侦探提供另一份供词。
Grant denied making sexual advances to WeTheGirl, but claimed that after the crash, Cindy had come on to him. Grant said he had crawled out through the passenger door and saw her lying back on the top, pulling her clothes off and asking, Do you want me now? He allegedly ignored her and instead went to check on Mona, who had seemingly been thrown from the vehicle. When he asked if she was alright, she groaned in response, prompting him to believe she was fine.
格兰特否认对这名女孩（原文如此）进行性骚扰，但声称车祸发生后，辛迪主动贴上了他。格兰特说，他从乘客侧车门爬出来，看到她仰面躺在车顶上，脱掉衣服并问：“你现在想要我吗？”他声称自己无视了她，转而去查看似乎被甩出车外的莫娜。当他问她是否还好时，她呻吟着回应，这让他以为她没事。
Grant claimed he then joined Cindy on the top and decided to have a beer. The interview concluded at 12.20pm. Detective Resman told Grant that he would make further inquiries about the matter and speak to him again at a later date, adding, Quote, If you leave town, let me know where I can contact you. Grant replied, Yeah, it might be a good idea to get away for a while. I'll let you know where I'll be. That afternoon, Dawn and June Smith viewed the victim's bodies at Burke Hospital and
格兰特声称随后他回到车顶加入辛迪，并决定喝杯啤酒。采访于中午12点20分结束。雷斯曼侦探告诉格兰特，他将对该事件进行进一步调查，并在晚些时候再次找他谈话，并补充说：“原文：如果你离开这个镇，让我知道在哪里可以联系到你。”格兰特回答说：“是的，离开一段时间可能是个好主意。我会让你知道我在哪里的。”那天下午，道恩和琼·史密斯在伯克医院查看了受害者的尸体，
confirmed that they were their daughters, Cindy and Mona. News of the tragedy spread throughout Burke and the town became gripped by despair. When it was discovered the police hadn't arrested the man involved in the crash, this despair quickly turned to anger. Recent events in the region had already led to a somewhat fraught relationship between the Indigenous community and local law enforcement. Several months earlier, on August 6, 1987, a 27-year-old Aboriginal man named Lloyd Boney was arrested in the nearby town of Brewerna after breaching his bail conditions.
并确认她们就是他们的女儿辛迪和莫娜。悲剧的消息传遍了整个伯克，全镇陷入了绝望。当人们发现警方尚未逮捕涉案男子时，这种绝望迅速演变成了愤怒。该地区最近发生的事件已经导致原住民社区与当地执法部门之间的关系有些紧张。几个月前的1987年8月6日，一名叫劳埃德·博尼（Lloyd Boney）的27岁原住民男子因违反保释条件在附近的布鲁维纳（Brewerna）镇被捕。
He was taken into custody and found dead just 95 minutes later, with police saying they had found his body suspended by the neck with a football sock. Lloyd's friends and family suspected that the death was not a suicide, though this theory was dismissed in an official inquiry. After Lloyd's funeral on August 15, a violent riot broke out between members of Brewerna's Indigenous community and the police. Although Brewerna was about 100 kilometers east of Burke, it wasn't uncommon for police officers in the region to work cases across various towns.
他被拘留，仅在95分钟后就被发现死亡，警察称他们发现他的尸体被一双足球袜悬挂在颈部。劳埃德的朋友和家人怀疑这起死亡不是自杀，尽管这一理论在官方调查中被驳回。8月15日劳埃德的葬礼后，布鲁维纳的原住民社区成员与警方之间爆发了激烈的骚乱。尽管布鲁维纳在伯克以东约100公里处，但该地区的警官跨多个城镇处理案件并不罕见。
One of the officers injured in the riot, Detective Sergeant Vaughn Reed, was assigned to investigate Cindy and Mona Smith's deaths alongside Detective Asman. In a book about the case titled Angonia Road, author Richard Stanton argues that the subsequent bad blood between police and the Indigenous community meant that Burke police were unhappy about having to investigate the fatal crash several months later. This view is shared by some of Cindy and Mona's family members. On the night of December 6, less than 24 hours after Cindy and Mona's deaths, Alexander Grant traveled to Ningen, a town almost 200 kilometers southeast of Burke.
骚乱中受伤的警官之一、侦探中士沃恩·里德（Vaughn Reed）被指派与阿斯曼侦探一起调查辛迪和莫娜·史密斯的死因。在关于该案名为《安戈尼亚路》（Angonia Road）的书籍中，作者理查德·斯坦顿（Richard Stanton）辩称，随后警察与原住民社区之间的恶劣关系意味着伯克警方对不得不几个月后调查这起致命车祸感到不满。辛迪和莫娜的一些家属也持这种观点。12月6日晚，即辛迪和莫娜死后不到24小时，亚历山大·格兰特前往了距离伯克东南近200公里的宁根（Ningen）。
After Grant's ute was towed to the police station, it was later transferred back to the farm in North Burke where he was employed, as it actually belonged to Grant's employers who had been leasing it out to him. At 3pm on Sunday December 6, a crime scene officer went to the property to photograph the vehicle. It was examined again the following day by Senior Constable John Ludwig of the Crime Scene Unit Physical Evidence section. He noted that the roof had been crushed down into the top of the driver's seat and to the
格兰特的皮卡车被拖到警察局后，后来被转移回他受雇的北伯克农场，因为这辆车实际上属于格兰特的雇主，雇主将其租给了他。12月6日星期日，下午3点，一名犯罪现场警官前往该物业拍摄车辆照片。犯罪现场组物理证据科的高级警官约翰·路德维希（John Ludwig）于次日再次对其进行了检查。他注意到车顶被向下压扁，贴在驾驶座顶部和
middle of the steering wheel. Senior Constable Ludwig also visited the crash site to take further photographs. Detectives in Burke pieced together the events leading up to the crash. Grant had said he spent the morning of Saturday December 5 working at the Cotton Gin in North Burke until his excavator broke down. At 2.30pm, he went to the Oxford Hotel in town in search of someone who could give him a replacement part to repair the excavator. Despite originally telling the police he didn't start drinking until around 5.30pm, bar staff
方向盘中部。高级警官路德维希还访问了车祸现场以拍摄更多照片。伯克的侦探们拼凑了导致车祸发生的事件。格兰特曾说他12月5日星期六上午一直在北伯克的轧棉厂工作，直到他的挖掘机抛锚。下午2点30分，他去镇上的牛津酒店（Oxford Hotel）寻找能提供更换零件以修理挖掘机的人。尽管最初告诉警察他直到下午5点半左右才开始喝酒，但牛津酒店的
at the Oxford Hotel confirmed he'd drunk six beers in a two-hour period. From there, he went to two more pubs, drinking a beer at H, before returning to the Oxford Hotel where he had eight more. Over six hours, he had consumed 16 beers or 17.6 standard drinks. Throughout the evening, a number of witnesses had also seen Cindy and Mona in Burke, though only two were interviewed by police. 15-year-olds Betty Ann Edwards and Karen Johnson provided statements that they'd seen Cindy and Mona with Grant on the night in question.
酒吧员工证实他在两小时内喝了六杯啤酒。从那里，他去了另外两家酒吧，在H喝了一杯啤酒，然后返回牛津酒店又喝了八杯。在六个小时内，他喝了16杯啤酒或相当于17.6个标准饮酒量。整个晚上，许多目击者也在伯克看到了辛迪和莫娜，但警方只讯问了其中两人。15岁的贝蒂·安·爱德华兹（Betty Ann Edwards）和凯伦·约翰逊（Karen Johnson）提供了证词，称她们在出事当晚看到辛迪和莫娜与格兰特在一起。
At around 8.15pm, Betty Ann and Karen had been walking in the direction of the reserve when a white man pulled over in a Toyota Hilux and offered them a lift. They declined, but Cindy and Mona who were sitting nearby outside the home of a friend ran over. They asked the driver if he would take them across to a levee that marked the crossing point between Burke and the reserve. Betty Ann described the driver as somewhat slow and dopy as though he was drunk. When he reached across to open the car door, she saw half a carton of beer next to him
晚上8点15分左右，贝蒂·安和凯伦正朝保留地方向走去，一辆白色的丰田海拉克斯停了下来，车上男子提出送她们一程。她们拒绝了，但坐在附近朋友家门外的辛迪和莫娜跑了过来。她们问司机是否愿意带她们穿过标志着伯克与保留地交界处的堤坝。贝蒂·安形容司机有些反应迟钝、昏昏沉沉的，就像喝醉了一样。当他伸手去开车门时，她看到他身边有一半纸箱的啤酒
and a stubby in his hand. Betty Ann believed that the man drove off with the girls, but they were seen in the same area about 15 minutes later by one of Cindy's brothers who was walking home from visiting an auntie. At 9pm, they were also spotted by Mona's cousin, Daniel Booth, heading to the reserve on foot. Neither of these men were interviewed by investigators. After Grant was seen speaking with the girls at 8.15, he went back to the Oxford Hotel
手里还拿着一瓶啤酒。贝蒂·安认为那个男子载着女孩们开车走了，但大约15分钟后，辛迪的一位从阿姨家走回家的哥哥在同一个区域看到了她们。晚上9点，莫娜的表弟丹尼尔·布思也看到她们步行前往保留地。这两人都没有接受调查人员的讯问。在格兰特8点15分被看到与女孩们说话后，他回到了牛津酒店
to buy a six pack of beer, then went to the Carrier's Arms Hotel, where he drank six glasses of bourbon and coke and four more beers. He left at around 9.30pm and was next seen half an hour later at the Riverview Hotel. A barman said that Grant had entered alone, but he thought he saw an indigenous girl waiting for him by the doorway. Grant bought half a bottle of rum, two bottles of coke, and another six pack of beer. In total, he'd drunk the equivalent of 30 standard drinks throughout the day and had half a bottle of rum and 12 stubs of beer in his possession.
买了一箱六瓶装的啤酒，然后去了运载者武器酒店，在那里他喝了六杯波旁可乐和另外四杯啤酒。他在晚上9点30分左右离开，半小时后在河景酒店（Riverview Hotel）再次被看到。一名酒保说格兰特是独自进来的，但他认为他看到一个原住民女孩在门口等他。格兰特买了一半瓶朗姆酒、两瓶可乐和另一箱六瓶装啤酒。总的来说，他一整天喝的酒相当于30个标准饮酒量，并且拥有半瓶朗姆酒和12瓶啤酒。
Experienced pathologist Dr Clive Pringle travelled more than 370 kilometres from the city of Dubbo to perform Cindy and Mona's autopsies. They concluded that Mona, who was recovered face down by the shoulder of the road, had suffered severe head injuries and internal bleeding, causing her to pass away quickly following the crash. Cindy, who was found on the Tarpaulin, had deep abrasions across her face, chest, abdomen and back. Dr Pringle found a dried substance on her inner legs, which he thought could be seminal
经验丰富的病理学家克莱夫·普林格尔博士（Dr Clive Pringle）从达博（Dubbo）市驱车370多公里赶来对辛迪和莫娜进行尸检。他们的结论是，被发现在路肩上脸朝下的莫娜头部严重受伤且内出血，导致她在车祸后很快死亡。被发现在防水油布上的辛迪面部、胸部、腹部和背部有深深的擦伤。普林格尔博士在她的大腿内侧发现了一种干燥的物质，他认为这可能是精液
fluid. He took swabs of the substance, which were given to a scientific officer and transferred to the Department of Forensic Biology for testing. Cindy had suffered a perforated liver and a large laceration to her bladder, leading to severe hemorrhaging and a tear to a major muscle in the lower abdomen that is crucial to walking. Dr Pringle noted that while she may not have died immediately, she would have succumbed to her injuries quickly, and it was highly unlikely she was conscious following the crash.
。他采集了该物质的拭子，交给了科学官员并转交法医生物学部进行检测。辛迪的肝脏穿孔，膀胱有大撕裂伤，导致严重出血，并且下腹部对行走至关重要的主要肌肉撕裂。普林格尔博士指出，虽然她可能不是立即死亡，但她会很快死于伤势，并且在车祸后几乎不可能保持清醒。
He concluded that neither of the girls had been wearing seatbelts. The findings from the autopsies were not passed along to either of the girls' families. The only official information they were given regarding Cindy and Mona's deaths was a coroner's report. After receiving Dr Pringle's report, detectives Asman and Reid were inclined to believe that Mona had been driving Grant's Ute as he had claimed. The severity of her injuries, combined with the significant damage to the vehicle's side and Grant's lack of wounds, indicated to them that Grant was telling the truth.
他得出结论，两个女孩都没有系安全带。尸检结果并未转交给两个女孩的家属。他们关于辛迪和莫娜死讯获得的唯一官方信息是一份验尸报告。在收到普林格尔博士的报告后，阿斯曼和里德侦探倾向于相信莫娜一直在开格兰特的皮卡，正如他所声称的那样。她伤势的严重程度，加上车辆侧面的严重损坏以及格兰特缺乏伤口，向他们表明格兰特说的是实话。
At 7pm on Tuesday, December 8, the two detectives travelled to Ningen to interview Grant again. He was wearing the same clothes that he'd had on during the crash and was staying at a cheap hotel. Grant claimed that his wife had kicked him out for having been with Cindy and Mona, and the detectives noted that he appeared to be intoxicated. They informed him that they wished to discuss the crash, but he requested that the conversation be postponed until the following morning, as he was exhausted. The detectives agreed and collected him early on Wednesday, December 9, for an interview
12月8日星期二晚上7点，两名侦探前往宁根再次讯问格兰特。他穿着车祸时穿的同一套衣服，住在一家廉价酒店里。格兰特声称他的妻子因为他跟辛迪和莫娜在一起而把他赶了出来，侦探们注意到他看起来喝醉了。他们通知他希望讨论车祸事宜，但他请求将谈话推迟到次日上午，因为他筋疲力尽。侦探们同意了，并于12月9日星期三清晨将他接走进行
at the police station. The officers grilled Grant about his alcohol consumption the previous Saturday. He acknowledged being pretty drunk by the time he encountered Cindy and Mona, but denied drinking the bottle of rum that was found nearly empty in his vehicle. He said that following the crash, he and Cindy had both climbed out of the passenger side door, then Cindy had stood and asked for a beer. He gave her the bottle that was later found on the tarpaulin, and after drinking some, she propositioned him.
警察局审讯。警官们盘问了格兰特上周六的饮酒情况。他承认在遇到辛迪和莫娜时已经喝得烂醉，但否认喝了在他车里发现的那瓶几乎见空的朗姆酒。他说，车祸发生后，他和辛迪都从乘客侧车门爬了出来，然后辛迪站起来要了一瓶啤酒。他给了她后来在防水油布上发现的那瓶酒，在她喝了一些后，她向他求欢。
Grant insisted he had not placed the tarpaulin on the ground, and that Cindy had walked over to it and laid down of her own accord. He didn't remember much else, and suggested he had blacked out, until he was awoken by the farm workers who came across the scene. Grant again claimed Cindy undressed herself, and that he'd had no sexual contact with either of the girls. He said that the one mistake he made that night was not checking whether Mona had her driver's license.
格兰特坚称他没有把防水油布铺在地上，是辛迪自己走过去躺在上面的。他不记得其他太多事情，暗示自己已经不省人事，直到被路过现场的农场工人唤醒。格兰特再次声称辛迪是自己脱衣服的，他与两个女孩没有发生任何性接触。他说，那天晚上他犯的唯一错误是没有检查莫娜是否有驾照。
The interview concluded after two and a half hours. It was another week before Grant was officially charged. Rather than taking him back to Burke, police made the decision to charge him in Ningen. On Wednesday, December 16, he appeared in the Ningen courthouse, charged with two counts of willful neglect or misconduct causing grievous bodily harm, and allowing an unlicensed driver to drive his motor vehicle. In 1987, there was a maximum penalty of two years in prison for each of the willful neglect charges.
讯问在两个半小时后结束。又过了一个星期，格兰特才被正式起诉。警方没有把他带回伯克，而是决定在宁根起诉他。12月16日星期三，他出现在宁根法院，被控两项蓄意疏忽或失职导致严重身体伤害罪，以及允许无证司机驾驶其机动车的罪名。1987年，每项蓄意疏忽罪最高可判处两年监禁。
The punishment for permitting an unlicensed individual to drive was a $1,000 fine and up to 500 hours community service. Grant was ordered to appear in Burke local court in two months' time to enter a plea. He was not detained in custody, and was permitted to leave the area following these charges. Police were instructed not to reveal details of the charges, leaving Cindy and Mona's families uncertain as to what the exact accusations against him were. A joint funeral was held for Cindy and Mona at the Church of the Holy Spirit in Burke. Two herces carried the girls' coffins through the town, and approximately 600 mourners gathered
允许无证人员驾驶的惩罚是1,000美元罚款以及长达500小时的社区服务。法庭下令格兰特在两个月内出庭伯克地方法院进行抗辩。他没有被拘留，并被允许在这些指控后离开该地区。警方被指示不得透露指控的细节，这使得辛迪和莫娜的家属对针对他的确切指控感到茫然。辛迪和莫娜的联合葬礼在伯克的圣灵教堂（Church of the Holy Spirit）举行。两辆灵车载着女孩们的棺材穿过小镇，大约600名哀悼者聚集在一起
to pay their respects, with students from the town's high school forming a guard of honour outside the church. The majority of the people who attended the funeral were indigenous. The cousins were laid to rest side by side in the Burke cemetery, under matching black marble headstones adorned with figurines, rosary beads, and flowers. Mona's sister Fiona would later say that she could recall little about the service, as her memory was hazy when it came to events following her sister's death. Some people in Burke feared that there would be retribution from the indigenous community
表达敬意，镇上高中的学生在教堂外组成了仪仗队。参加葬礼的大多数人都是原住民。表亲们被安葬在伯克墓地的并排位置，墓碑是配套的黑色大理石，上面装饰着小雕像、玫瑰念珠和鲜花。莫娜的姐姐菲奥娜后来表示，她对葬礼几乎没有什么记忆，因为在妹妹去世后的事件上，她的记忆有些模糊。伯克的一些人担心原住民社区会进行报复
that night, with rumours spreading that businesses would be firebombed, but this did not eventuate. The girls' deaths and Grant's involvement received almost no attention from the media. On Monday, December 21, the Sydney Morning Herald published an article titled, Two deaths and an outback silence. Journalist Deborah Cameron interviewed Cindy and Mona's mothers for the piece, with both women stating they had been told very little about the crash, how their daughters had died, or the investigation. Dawn Smith, Cindy's mother, shared her belief that police were withholding information because
那天晚上，有传言称企业将被火烧，但这种情况并没有发生。女孩们的死以及格兰特的卷入几乎没有受到媒体的关注。12月21日星期一，《悉尼先驱晨报》发表了一篇题为《两起死亡与内陆的沉默》的文章。记者黛博拉·卡梅伦在文章中采访了辛迪和莫娜的母亲，两位女性都表示，她们对这起车祸、女儿们是如何死以及调查情况知之甚少。辛迪的母亲道恩·史密斯表示，她相信警方隐瞒信息是因为
they didn't want to stir up trouble in town, but the silence had the adverse effect by creating an atmosphere of rumour and suspicion. The Sydney Morning Herald made an application for information about the case. Smith has agreed to release details relating to Grant's charges only after an Aboriginal liaison officer from Sydney intervened, telling them that, quote, their secrecy may cause more trouble than it would prevent. The head of Burke police defended the decision to charge Grant in another town, stating, He won't come back down here either until things quieten down.
他们不想在镇上挑起事端，但这种沉默却适得其反，反而制造了一种流言蜚语和猜忌的氛围。《悉尼先驱晨报》就此案申请了信息公开。在悉尼的一名原住民联络官进行干预，并告知他们“其保密行为可能带来的麻烦比避免的还要多”之后，史密斯才同意公开与格兰特指控相关的细节。伯克警察局长在另一个城镇为起诉格兰特的决定进行了辩护，称：“在事情平息之前，他也不会回到这里来。”
We will wait until things settle down again. We don't want any trouble. Alexander Grant had little money and almost no assets, but in January 1988, one of his former employers agreed to fund his defence. The unidentified employer was described as being from old Sydney family money and had decided to pay for Grant's legal fees out of a sense of, quote, higher Christian values. Leading Sydney Barrister Anthony Quinlivan was hired to represent Grant at an expensive rate said to be, beyond the income of most average people.
我们将等待局势再次平息。我们不希望有任何麻烦。亚历山大·格兰特几乎没有什么钱，也没有什么资产，但在1988年1月，他的一位前雇主同意资助他的辩护。这位未透露姓名的雇主被描述为来自悉尼的老牌家族财富，决定出于某种“更高的基督教价值观”来支付格兰特的律师费。悉尼知名大律师安东尼·昆利文被聘用以高昂的价格代表格兰特辩护，据说这个价格“超出了大多数普通人的收入”。
After that month, Grant wrote a new statement about the crash for his legal team, which was republished in full in Richard Stanton's book, Angonia Road. Despite telling police he had a wife, Grant described himself as single, but otherwise stuck to many of his original claims. He stated that his intoxication had probably contributed to him making the uncharacteristic decision to give Cindy and Mona Smith a lift and letting Mona drive his vehicle. Grant said that after driving for some distance, they stopped to have a drink. He claimed that the girls poured some rum into the bottles of coke he had purchased
在那之后的一个月里，格兰特为他的法律团队写了一份关于车祸的新陈述，理查德·斯坦顿的书中全文转载了这份陈述，书名为《安戈尼亚路》。尽管曾告诉警方他有一个妻子，但格兰特在陈述中称自己是单身，但在其他方面仍然坚持他最初的许多说法。他表示，他的醉酒状态可能促使他做出了不符合其性格的决定，让辛迪和莫娜·史密斯搭便车，并让莫娜驾驶他的车。格兰特说，在行驶了一段距离后，他们停下来喝一杯。他声称，女孩们把一些朗姆酒倒进了他买的可乐瓶里
before the decision was made to head home. Mona had been steering the vehicle steadily up until that point, but suddenly veered off the road, possibly to avoid a kangaroo. The ute rolled over, then landed on its wheels. Grant retracted previous claims he'd made about Cindy undressing herself and propositioning him, stating now that he didn't recall this happening. Yet, he said that he did remember checking to see if Mona was all right. At that point, he had a gap in his memory until the farm workers stumbled across the
然后在决定回家之前。在此之前，莫娜一直平稳地控制着方向盘，但突然猛打方向盘冲出路面，可能是为了躲避一只袋兽。这辆皮卡翻了车，然后四个轮子着地。格兰特收回了他以前关于辛迪自己脱衣服并向他求欢的说法，现在改口称他不记得发生过这种事。不过，他说他确实记得检查过莫娜是否没事。在那之后，他的记忆出现了空白，直到筑路工人在凌晨4点30分无意中发现了车祸现场。
scene of the crash at 4.30am. Barrister Anthony Quinlaven accompanied his client to Burke Local Court on Monday, February 15, where Grant entered a plea of not guilty to all three charges against him. Although farm employee Shane Batty had been one of the first people to discover the crash site. This didn't speak with him until three months after the incident. Author Richard Stanton has theorized that this may have been because Shane was a seasonal worker and investigators were unable to track him down earlier.
大律师安东尼·昆利文于2月15日星期一陪同他的当事人前往伯克地方法院，格兰特在法庭上对针对他的所有三项指控均表示不认罪。尽管农场员工谢恩·巴蒂是第一批发现车祸现场的人之一，但直到事件发生三个月后才找他谈话。作家理查德·斯坦顿推测，这可能是因为谢恩是一名季节工，调查人员无法更早地追踪到他。
On March 8, 1988, Shane provided a sworn statement at Deighton Police Station, located about 680km southwest of Burke. Shane's description of the scene featured some striking differences to the one described by responding police and ambulance officers. The officers had noted that Cindy's pants had been pulled down and her t-shirt was lifted up, exposing almost her entire body. While her right leg was stretched out straight in front of her, her left leg was bent at the knee and had fallen outwards.
1988年3月8日，谢恩在位于伯克西南约680公里的代顿警察局提供了一份宣誓供词。谢恩对现场的描述与出警的警察和救护人员描述的场景有一些显著的不同。警员们曾注意到辛迪的裤子被拉了下来，T恤被掀起，几乎露出了她的整个身体。她的右腿笔直地伸在身体前面，而左腿则在膝盖处弯曲并向外倒下。
When Shane had encountered the scene more than an hour earlier, Cindy's pants and underwear were around her ankles, but her t-shirt was pulled down, concealing her chest and torso. Shane also noted that both of Cindy's legs had been lying straight out, side by side. To investigators, these discrepancies indicated that Grant must have interfered with Cindy's clothing and body after the farm workers departed for Angonia to alert police of the crash. They also meant that his statements regarding the events had been at least partially false. The case shifted direction again the following month, when a new officer began reviewing the charges against Grant.
当谢恩在一个多小时前遇到这个现场时，辛迪的裤子和内衣都在脚踝处，但她的T恤是被拉下来的，遮住了她的胸部和躯干。谢恩还注意到，辛迪的两腿并拢，笔直地伸着。对调查人员来说，这些出入表明，在农场工人离开安戈尼亚向警方报警车祸后，格兰特一定对辛迪的衣物和身体进行了干涉。这也意味着他关于事件的陈述至少有部分是虚假的。接下来的一个月，随着一名新警官开始重新审查对格兰特的指控，案件再次迎来了方向上的转变。
Raymond Godkin worked for the Northwest Accident Investigation Squad in the New South Wales City of Parramatta. His job was to review indictable matters before the courts. After reviewing the case of Cindy and Mona Smith's deaths, he became concerned that the charges against Grant were not truly representative of what had occurred that night. Sergeant Godkin noticed that when police officers had first arrived at the scene, Grant had said that he'd been driving. Shortly afterwards, he had changed his story and told them Mona was the driver, a claim
雷蒙德·戈德金在新南威尔士州帕拉马塔市西北事故调查组工作。他的工作是审查法院审理前的公诉案件。在审查了辛迪和莫娜·史密斯死亡案后，他开始担心对格兰特的指控并不能真正代表当晚发生的事情。戈德金警长注意到，当警官们最初到达现场时，格兰特曾说一直是他在开车。但不久之后，他改变了说法，告诉他们莫娜才是司机，这一说法
he had stuck to ever since. Sergeant Godkin spoke with Mona's family to determine whether she could actually drive a car. Mona's brother Doug stated that she had only tried to drive a car once. Several months before the crash, a friend had brought their blue Ford sedan to the reserve and Mona had sat behind the wheel for less than five minutes. She slowly manoeuvred the car down a dirt road before getting out. The vehicle was an automatic, unlike Alexander Grant's four-wheel drive, which was a manual.
他从那时起一直坚持到现在。戈德金警长与莫娜的家人交谈，以确定她是否真的会开车。莫娜的弟弟道格表示，她只试着开过一次车。在车祸发生前几个月，一个朋友把他们的蓝色福特轿车开到了保护区，莫娜坐在方向盘后面不到五分钟。她慢慢地把车沿着土路开了一段，然后下了车。这是一辆自动档汽车，而亚历山大·格兰特的四轮驱动车则是手动档。
Doug stated, I am sure that she has never driven any other car. If someone told me Mona drove a manual car, I wouldn't believe them, because she just doesn't know how to drive. Doug's statement was supported by Mona's cousin Daniel Booth and her mother June, who both witnessed her brief drive in the sedan. June added that Mona had accidentally reversed into a steel pole, at which point June immediately told her to get out of the car.
道格表示：“我确信她从来没有开过别的车。如果有人告诉我莫娜开过手动档汽车，我是不会相信的，因为她根本就不会开车。”道格的说法得到了莫娜的表弟丹尼尔·布思和她的母亲琼的证实，他们两人都目睹了她短暂驾驶那辆轿车的全过程。琼补充说，莫娜不小心倒车撞上了一根钢柱，当时琼立刻叫她下车。
Cindy's mother Dawn had later heard about the incident and stated, We are a very close community, and if Mona was driving at any time, then I would hear about it. Anybody who said that Mona was driving the four-wheel drive that was involved in the accident would be lying, because she just couldn't drive it. Several days after interviewing Mona's relatives, Sergeant Godkin arranged to speak with Alexander Grant on May 11, 1988. Grant initially declined to speak without his lawyer present.
辛迪的母亲道恩后来听说了这起事件，并表示：“我们是一个非常紧密的社区，如果莫娜在任何时候开过车，我都会听到风声。任何说莫娜开了那辆卷入事故的四轮驱动车的人都是在撒谎，因为她根本不会开。”在采访了莫娜的亲属几天后，戈德金警长安排于1988年5月11日与亚历山大·格兰特谈话。格兰特最初拒绝在没有律师在场的情况下发言。
But when Sergeant Godkin asked whether there was anything he wanted to say in their absence, he remarked Well, I've thought about it, and a lot of the stuff I told the detectives is not right, and some of the things I said is really bullshit. He discussed the night of December 5, 1987 openly, admitting that he had been far more drunk than he had told the detectives. Grant maintained that Cindy and Mona had approached him asking for a lift, and Mona had driven the vehicle for a good portion of the journey, adding, quote,
但当戈德金警长询问在他们不在场的情况下他是否有话要说时，他评论道：“好吧，我考虑过了，我告诉侦探们的很多东西都不对，我说的有些话简直是一派胡言。”他公开讨论了1987年12月5日晚上的情况，承认自己比告诉侦探们的要醉得多。格兰特坚称辛迪和莫娜曾主动要求他带她们一程，而且莫娜在行程的很大一部分时间里都开着车，并补充道：“
She drove pretty good and handled it real well, really good on the gears. He claimed that when the vehicle crashed, Mona had gone through the windscreen, while he and Cindy remained stuck inside. He was sitting next to the passenger door, and Cindy was in the middle, so he opened the door, clambered out, and pulled Cindy out after him. When Sergeant Godkin asked if Grant recalled telling the detectives that Cindy had been walking around after the crash, he replied From what I have heard since about her injuries, that can't be right.
她开得相当不错，处理得非常好，换档非常熟练。”他声称，当车辆撞毁时，莫娜从挡风玻璃飞了出去，而他和辛迪则被困在车内。他坐在副驾驶车门旁，辛迪坐在中间，于是他打开车门，艰难地爬了出去，然后把辛迪也拉了出来。当戈德金警长询问格兰特是否记得曾告诉侦探辛迪在车祸后曾四处走动时，他回答说：“从我后来听到的关于她受伤的情况来看，那是不可能的。”
Like I said, a lot of the things I have said isn't right. He claimed that her clothing must have been pulled down accidentally when he dragged her from the vehicle. Sergeant Godkin reiterated Grant's extremely high blood alcohol level of 0.159 when tested hours after the crash. Then stated Grant replied I know I did the wrong thing letting her drive without a license.
“就像我说的，我说的很多事情都不对。”他声称，当他把她从车里拖出来时，她的衣服一定是无意中被拉下来的。戈德金警长重申了车祸发生几小时后测试显示格兰特血液酒精浓度极高，达到了0.159。随后表示，格兰特回答道：“我知道我做错了，不该让她在没有驾照的情况下开车。”
On Saturday, May 14, Sergeant Godkin arranged for a physical evidence collector from the crime investigation unit to re-examine Grant's Toyota Hilux. Although the vehicle was significantly damaged, Grant's employers had sold it to a man named Peter Hurle, whom Grant knew and was friendly with, and Peter had spent some time attempting to repair it. He'd noted that when he received the vehicle, the passenger side door was open and its lock had been damaged in a way that was consistent with having been forced open with a crowbar. The physical evidence collector photographed the Toyota Hilux and tested the inside cabin
5月14日星期六，戈德金警长安排犯罪调查局的物证收集员重新检查格兰特的丰田海拉克斯。尽管这辆车严重受损，但格兰特的雇主把它卖给了一个名叫彼得·赫尔的人，格兰特认识他并且两人关系不错，彼得花了一些时间试图修复它。他指出，当他拿到这辆车时，副驾驶车门是开着的，其锁具受损，这与被人用撬棍强行撬开的情况一致。物证收集员拍摄了丰田海拉克斯的照片，并对车内舱进行了测试
for traces of blood. They immediately noticed that the steering wheel was missing and asked where it was. Peter said that he had removed it and shipped it to Grant the previous day at Grant's request. Investigators suspected Peter Hurle had told Grant that police were planning to inspect the vehicle, which had caused Grant to panic and ask for the steering wheel. Without it, officers were unable to dust it for fingerprints to confirm who had been driving. Nothing relating to the steering wheel was ever heard of again. In re-examining the case, Sergeant Godkin also took the step of speaking with the detectives
检查是否有血迹。他们立刻发现方向盘不见了，并询问它在哪里。彼得说，他应格兰特的要求，在前一天将其拆下并运给了格兰特。调查人员怀疑彼得·赫尔曾告诉格兰特警方计划检查这辆车，这导致格兰特惊慌失措并索要方向盘。没有了方向盘，警官们就无法提取指纹来确认当时是谁在驾驶。关于方向盘的任何线索从此再也没有出现过。在重新审查此案时，戈德金警长还采取了与侦探们交谈的步骤
involved and the first responders to the crash site. After doing so, he was certain that Cindy's body had been undressed and rearranged after being discovered by the farm workers. Although multiple swabs had been taken from Cindy's body during her autopsy, including a sample of what was believed to be seminal fluid, these were never tested, for unknown reasons. Consequently, there was no forensic evidence confirming whether she had been sexually assaulted.
以及车祸现场的第一响应者。在此之后，他确信辛迪的尸体在被农场工人发现后曾被剥去衣服并重新摆放。尽管在辛迪的尸体解剖过程中提取了多个棉签样本，包括一份被认为是精液的样本，但由于未知原因，这些样本从未经过检测。因此，没有法医证据可以证实她是否遭到性侵。
However, the eyewitness accounts provided enough evidence to charge Alexander Grant with indecently interfering with the dead body, which carried the maximum penalty of two years in prison. On May 24, 1988, Grant was officially charged with this offense, as well as two counts of culpable driving causing death, after Sergeant Godkin concluded that Mona would have been incapable of driving a manual four-wheel drive. He was also charged with high-range prescribed concentration of alcohol, a charge given to individuals who drive a motor vehicle on a public road with a blood alcohol concentration
然而，目击者的证词提供了足够的证据，以“蓄意干扰尸体”的罪名起诉亚历山大·格兰特，该罪名最高可判处两年监禁。1988年5月24日，在戈德金警长得出莫娜不可能驾驶手动四轮驱动车的结论后，格兰特被正式指控犯有此罪，以及两项导致死亡的过失驾驶罪。他还被指控达到法定高浓度酒精标准的驾驶罪，这一罪名适用于在公共道路上驾驶机动车辆时血液酒精浓度
of 0.15 or above. As the counts of culpable driving conflicted with Grant's original charge of allowing an unlicensed driver to take control of his vehicle, the decision was made to hold a committal hearing in order to determine which of the charges Grant would ultimately face. The committal hearing was held almost six months later on November 8, 1988. It was a hot day, making the Burt courthouse feel particularly stuffy and unpleasant. Magistrate Rosemarie Kada Smith presided over the hearing, while police prosecutor Sergeant Rowland today presented for the prosecution.
达到或超过0.15的个人。由于过失驾驶的指控与格兰特最初被指控的“允许无证驾驶员控制他的车辆”相冲突，因此决定举行听证会，以确定格兰特最终将面临哪项指控。听证会于近六个月后的1988年11月8日举行。那天天气炎热，使得伯克法院显得格外闷热和难受。地方法官罗丝玛丽·卡达·史密斯主持了听证会，而警察检察官罗兰警长则代表控方出庭。
Alexander Grant was represented by his high-priced barrister Anthony Quinloven and solicitor Bill Howes. The prosecution's primary aim was to disprove Grant's assertion that Mona Smith had been driving his vehicle. The defense pointed to the significant damage sustained to the driver's side of the Ute and argued that Grant was too large to have escaped essentially unscathed if he had been driving. As Mona had suffered extreme injuries, they posited that it was far more likely she had
亚历山大·格兰特由他高薪聘请的大律师安东尼·昆利文和诉讼律师比尔·豪斯代表。控方的首要目标是驳斥格兰特关于莫娜·史密斯一直在驾驶他的车的断言。辩方指出皮卡车驾驶侧受损严重，并辩称如果格兰特当时在开车，他的身材太胖，不可能基本上毫发无伤地逃生。由于莫娜遭受了极端的伤害，他们断言她更有可能是
been behind the wheel. The first witness called to the stand was Sergeant Raymond Godkin, whose work on the case had resulted in culpable driving charges being laid against Grant. Cindy and Mona's mothers, Dawn and June Smith, also testified, speaking about their relationships with their daughters, and both girls' lack of driving experience. The defense attempted to undermine the evidence of both women under cross-examination, suggesting that Mona might have had more experience driving than her family was aware of. While Dawn and June Smith both spoke of how close knit their community was, barrister Anthony
坐在方向盘后面的人。被传唤到证人席的第一位证人是雷蒙德·戈德金警长，他在该案中的工作导致了对格兰特的过失驾驶指控。辛迪和莫娜的母亲道恩和琼·史密斯也出庭作证，讲述了她们与女儿的关系，以及两个女孩都缺乏驾驶经验。辩方试图在盘问中削弱这两位女性的证词，暗示莫娜的驾驶经验可能比她的家人所知道的要丰富。虽然道恩和琼·史密斯都谈到她们的社区是多么紧密，但大律师安东尼·
Quinloven tried to discredit this by telling the court that the girls were known to drink on occasion and spend time unsupervised. Constable Ken McKenzie, the first officer to arrive on the scene, also testified, though he appeared nervous. The prosecution portrayed Constable McKenzie as a reliable officer with considerable crime scene experience, but the defense implied his failure to bring his official police notebook to the scene reflected poorly. Constable McKenzie confirmed that Grant had been slurring his words when questioned by
昆利文试图通过在法庭上声称女孩们偶尔喝酒且无人监管来抹黑这一点。第一位到达现场的警官肯·麦肯齐警员也出庭作证，尽管他看起来很紧张。控方将麦肯齐警员描绘成一名具有丰富犯罪现场经验的可靠警官，但辩方暗示他未能将官方警用笔记本带到现场，这反映出他表现不佳。麦肯齐警员证实，当被出警警员盘问时，格兰特说话口齿不清，这促使昆利文询问麦肯齐是否可能误解了他最初声称自己一直在开皮卡的说法。麦肯齐警员态度坚定，指出在回答谁在开车的问题时，格兰特明确表示：“是我。”
the responding officers, prompting Quinloven to query whether McKenzie had possibly misunderstood his initial claim that he had been driving the Ute. Constable McKenzie stood firm, noting that Grant had definitely stated, I was, in response to the question of who had been driving. Dr. Clive Pringle, the forensic pathologist who conducted Cindy and Mona's autopsies, told the court that both girls would have died within an hour of the crash. He further stated that Cindy would have been in extreme pain and unable to sit up and had likely fallen unconscious immediately following the crash due to shock and injuries.
克莱夫·普林格医生，即对辛迪和莫娜进行尸检的法医病理学家，在法庭上表示，两个女孩在车祸发生后的一小时内就会死亡。他进一步表示，辛迪当时会处于极度疼痛中，无法坐起来，并且可能由于休克和受伤而在车祸发生后立即失去知觉。
However, under cross-examination from Quinloven, Dr. Pringle acknowledged that it wouldn't be, quote, totally extraordinary if Cindy had managed to survive for up to two hours. Witnesses Shane Batty and Tex Johnson spoke of how they stumbled across the crash scene. Shane insisted that both girls were deceased when they arrived, but the defense argued he was not in a position to confirm this, as he had no medical experience. By trying to extend the period of time Cindy could have survived for, Grant's legal team were trying to convince the magistrate that Cindy could have still been alive after her body was undressed and adjusted, thus absolving Grant of having indecently interfered with
然而，在昆利文的交叉盘问下，普林格医生承认，如果辛迪设法存活长达两个小时，那也并非“完全非同寻常”。证人谢恩·巴蒂和特克斯·约翰逊讲述了他们如何偶然发现车祸现场。谢恩坚持认为他们到达时两个女孩都已经死亡，但辩方辩称他没有资格确认这一点，因为他没有任何医学经验。通过试图延长辛迪可能存活的时间，格兰特的法律团队试图让地方法官相信，辛迪的衣服在被脱掉并调整时可能仍然活着，从而免除格兰特对故意干扰尸体的指控。
the dead body. In summing up the case, Magistrate Rosemary Cadas Smith noted that although there was evidence suggesting that Mona Smith had driven a vehicle at least once before the crash, she did not have very extensive experience in driving. She also stated that Grant had clearly been dishonest when speaking with police and that it seemed highly out of character for him to lend his vehicle to a teenager whom he'd just met. Ultimately, Judge Cadas Smith determined that the original charges relating to Mona driving the vehicle would be dropped and Grant would face two counts of culpable driving.
在总结案件时，地方法官罗丝玛丽·卡达·史密斯指出，尽管有证据表明莫娜·史密斯在车祸前至少开过一次车，但她并没有非常丰富的驾驶经验。她还指出，格兰特在与警方交谈时明显不诚实，把车借给一个刚认识的十几岁女孩对他来说似乎很不符合性格。最终，卡达·史密斯法官裁定，撤销原先关于莫娜驾驶车辆的指控，格兰特将面临两项过失驾驶罪的指控。
With regards to the charge of indecently interfering with the dead body, Judge Cadas Smith noted that Cindy would have died quickly and dismissed the notion that she had removed her own clothing. Noting that Grant was discovered with his arm draped across Cindy's chest, indicating interference of a sexual nature had been committed, Judge Cadas Smith said that this third charge would also stand. Grant was committed for trial but was not held on remand. He was escorted from the courthouse to a car waiting outside. Some of Cindy and Mona's family and friends ran after the car as it drove away, shouting and shaking their fists with several making eye contact with Grant as they did so.
关于干扰死者尸体的指控，卡达·史密斯法官指出，辛迪会迅速死亡，并驳回了她自己脱衣服的想法。卡达·史密斯法官指出，人们发现格兰特的手臂搭在辛迪的胸前，这表明发生了带有性性质的干扰，并表示第三项指控也将成立。格兰特被交付审判，但未被还押候审。他被护送出法院，坐上了外面等待的一辆汽车。辛迪和莫娜的一些家人和朋友在汽车开走时追了上去，大喊大叫并挥舞着拳头，其中几人在这样做时与格兰特进行了眼神交流。
Grant had relocated to Sydney following the crash and returned there to await his trial. More than six months later, in June 1989, the charge of high-range prescribed concentration of alcohol was adjourned for unknown reasons. It was the only charge against Grant that Judge Cadas Smith didn't address during the conclusion of the committal hearing. The trial was scheduled for January 29, 1990. In the meantime, Grant's defence team requested that the NSW Attorney General issue a no-bill to the charge of indecent interference with the body. If a charge was given a no-bill, it would essentially go away and not be brought up during a trial. Grant's defence argued that there was no evidence beyond the reasonable
格兰特在车祸后搬到了悉尼，并在那里等待审判。六个多月后的1989年6月，由于未知原因，高浓度酒精超标驾驶的指控被休庭延期。这是卡达·史密斯法官在听证会结束时唯一没有处理的对格兰特的指控。审判原定于1990年1月29日举行。在此期间，格兰特的辩护团队要求新南威尔士州总检察长对干扰尸体指控发布“不予起诉”令。如果一项指控被给予“不予起诉”令，它基本上就会消失，不会在审判中被提出。格兰特的辩护辩称，没有超出合理怀疑的证据表明
doubt that Cindy was deceased at 5am, the approximate time that her shirt was removed. They also stated that Grant's advanced level of intoxication meant there was a question as to whether he was in a state to voluntarily undertake such an action. The Attorney General agreed with these arguments. And on January 24, 1990, the defence team received a letter from the Director of Public Prosecutions advising that the charge would be withdrawn. No other charge was introduced relating to the possible sexual assault of Cindy and the only charges Grant would be tried for were the two counts of culpable driving. Cindy and Mona's families were not informed that the charge of interference with the corpse
辛迪在凌晨5点（即她的衬衫被脱掉的大致时间）已经死亡。他们还表示，格兰特高度醉酒的状态意味着人们对他在这种状态下是否能够自愿采取这种行动产生了疑问。总检察长同意了这些论点。1990年1月24日，辩护团队收到来自公共检察署署长的一封信，通知该指控将被撤销。没有引入与辛迪可能遭性侵相关的其他指控，格兰特将受审的唯二指控是两项过失驾驶罪。辛迪和莫娜的家属直到2月1日星期四在伯克地方法院开庭审判时，才被告知干扰尸体的指控
had been dropped until the trial commenced on Thursday, February 1 in the Burke District Court. Upon hearing the news, they became furious and distraught. As the jury were required to exit the court whenever evidence relating to interference with Cindy's corpse was raised, they were entirely unaware of the matter or the withdrawn charge. The original jury had included two Aboriginal women, but Grant's defence had challenged their inclusion by arguing that they would be under pressure from their communities to convict and, quote, in those circumstances, Grant probably wouldn't get a fair trial. Consequently, the two Indigenous jury members were replaced, resulting in an all-white jury.
已被撤销。听到这个消息后，他们愤怒且痛苦万分。由于陪审团被要求在每次提出与干扰辛迪尸体相关的证据时离开法庭，他们对这件事或被撤销的指控一无所知。最初的陪审团曾包括两名原住民女性，但格兰特的辩护团队对她们的加入提出异议，辩称她们将承受来自其社区要求定罪的压力，并且“在这种情况下，格兰特可能无法获得公正的审判”。因此，这两名原住民陪审员被替换，导致陪审团全由白人组成。
The onus was on the prosecution to prove beyond the reasonable doubt that Alexander Grant had been driving the vehicle when it crashed. Their argument was hindered by what Grant's barrister later called, the fabulous physical evidence of the ute's roof being smashed in down to the steering wheel on the driver's side, quote. Anybody sitting in that seat was a goner and my guy didn't have a scratch. On Thursday, February 8, one week after the trial began, the jury returned a verdict of not guilty, prompting the court to erupt in anger. When the verdict was read aloud, Dawn Smith removed one of her shoes and threw it at the jury. She later spoke of her anger at the finding to journalist Rosemary Neal, who wrote an article
控方的责任是毫无合理怀疑地证明亚历山大·格兰特在车祸发生时正在驾驶该车辆。他们的论点受到了后来格兰特的辩护律师所说的“驾驶侧车顶被砸扁直到方向盘处的惊人物理证据”的阻碍。坐在那个座位上的任何人都是死路一条，而我的当事人却连一点擦伤都没有。在2月8日星期四，即审判开始一周后，陪审团给出了无罪的裁决，引发法庭一片愤怒。当裁决被大声宣读时，道恩·史密斯脱下一只鞋子向陪审团砸去。她后来向记者罗丝玛丽·尼尔讲述了她对这一裁决的愤怒，后者写了一篇文章
about the case titled, The Long Shadow of a Twin Tragedy for the Weekend Australian Newspaper. Dawn remarked, Of course I was shocked. June added that if a police officer had been standing near her, she would have grabbed their gun and shot Grant in retaliation. She recalled that two police officers also seemed bitterly disappointed by Grant's acquittal. In the same article, June Smith told Rosemary Neal that day was the worst of her life, quote. To hear what happened to these girls and he walked free. If it had been two little white girls, it would have been a different matter. And if it was a black man with two white girls, he would have been locked up there and then thrown away the keys, still in jail today.
关于这起案件，题为《周末澳大利亚人报》上的《双重悲剧的漫长阴影》。道恩评论说：“我当然很震惊。”琼补充说，如果当时有一名警察站在她附近，她会抢过他们的枪，开枪打死格兰特以示报复。她回忆说，两名警官似乎也对格兰特的无罪释放感到极度失望。在同一篇文章中，琼·史密斯告诉罗丝玛丽·尼尔，那一天是她一生中最糟糕的一天。“听到这些女孩遭遇了什么，而他却大摇大摆地走了。如果是两个小白人女孩，情况就会完全不同。如果是一个黑人男子带着两个白人女孩，他当时就会被关起来，钥匙也会被扔掉，直到今天还在监狱里。”
Due to the angry reaction from those in the public gallery, Grant's barrister and solicitor were given a police escort out of the courthouse. They were instructed by police to leave for Sydney immediately and not stop until they reached Bathurst, a town six hours away by car. Four days later, on February 12th, Grant was arrested in Sydney after severely assaulting another individual and was charged with assault-occasioning actual bodily harm. Many people in Burke were outraged and disgusted by the trial's outcome, feeling that justice had not been served. In the years that followed, the inconclusive nature of the case prompted alternate theories as to what really happened
由于公众旁听席上人群的愤怒反应，格兰特的出庭大律师和诉讼律师在警察的护送下走出了法院。他们被警察指示立即离开悉尼，一鼓作气开到巴瑟斯特（一个开车需要六小时的小镇）才能停下。四天后的2月12日，格兰特在悉尼因严重袭击他人而被捕，并被指控“袭击造成实际身体伤害”。伯克市的许多人对审判结果感到愤怒和厌恶，他们觉得正义没有得到伸张。在随后的几年里，该案的不确定性质引发了关于
on Angonia Road on the night of December 5, 1987. They have been fuelled in part by a police statement made in May 1987 by a 13-year-old cousin of Cindy and Mona named Sharon Smith. Sharon told police that on the evening of Friday, December 4, the night before the crash, she had been walking through Burke towards the reserve with another cousin named Julie when a white four-wheel drive she believed was a Toyota pulled over. The driver was a white man who she later identified as Alexander Grant. He smelled of beer and asked if the girls knew where the nearby Rodeo was. The girls agreed to show him the way and got into his vehicle. Upon arriving at the showgrounds where the Rodeo was hosted,
1987年12月5日晚在安戈尼亚路上究竟发生了什么的各种不同理论。这些猜测部分是由辛迪和莫娜13岁的表妹莎伦·史密斯于1987年5月向警方做出的陈述所助长。莎伦告诉警方，在12月4日星期五晚上（即车祸前一晚），她正和另一个名叫朱莉的表妹穿过伯克走向保护区，这时一辆她认为是丰田的白色四轮驱动车停了下来。司机是一个白人男子，她后来认出他就是亚历山大·格兰特。他浑身散发着啤酒味，并询问女孩们是否知道附近的牛仔竞技表演在哪里。女孩们同意给他指路，并上了他的车。到达举办牛仔竞技表演的展览场后，
the girls started drinking with Grant. Soon, Sharon noticed that Cindy was also there. At some stage, Sharon, Julie, Cindy and Grant headed towards Angonia to visit Julie's brother. During the drive, Grant requested that Sharon steer the vehicle as he was extremely drunk. As she did so, Grant began rubbing the legs of all three girls. The group spent some time in Angonia before heading back towards Burke. When they arrived to back at the showgrounds, they encountered five more of Sharon's cousins who all wanted a lift. They piled into the rear cargo area of the Ute and before they were dropped off, they stole a number of work tools that had been stored there.
女孩们开始和格兰特一起喝酒。不久，莎伦注意到辛迪也在那里。在某个时刻，莎伦、朱莉、辛迪和格兰特前往安戈尼亚探望朱莉的兄弟。在开车期间，格兰特要求莎伦开车，因为他喝得酩酊大醉。在她开车时，格兰特开始揉捏三个女孩的腿。一行人在安戈尼亚待了一段时间后返回伯克。当他们回到展览场时，他们遇到了另外五个莎伦的表亲，他们都想搭便车。他们挤进了卡车的后货舱，在被放下车之前，他们偷走了存放在那里的许多工作工具。
Sharon said she then dropped Cindy off at the reserve, leaving her and Julie alone with Grant. He was extremely drunk at this point and propositioned the young girls, offering them money in exchange for sex. They refused and got out of the vehicle, at which point, Grant drove away. Some people in Burke believed that Cindy and Mona's deaths the following night were deliberately orchestrated by Grant as revenge for being robbed and that he mistook Mona for Julie. There are rumors that Julie had stolen drugs and a substantial amount of cash which Grant had stashed under one of the vehicle's seats. When Grant came into town the following day, supposedly looking for someone to help him repair his excavator, he was actually looking for Sharon,
莎伦说她随后把辛迪放在保护区，只留下她和朱莉与格兰特在一起。此时他已经酩酊大醉，并对年轻女孩们进行调戏，用钱换取性服务。她们拒绝了并下了车，就在这时，格兰特开车离去。伯克的一些人认为，辛迪和莫娜次晚的死亡是格兰特为了报复被抢劫而精心策划的，他误把莫娜当成了朱莉。有传言称，朱莉偷走了藏在车座下的毒品和一大笔现金。当格兰特第二天来到镇上，表面上是在找人帮他修理挖掘机时，在发现自己被抢后，他其实是在找莎伦、
Julie and Cindy after discovering he'd been robbed. Those that subscribe to this theory believed that several Aboriginal men who had been in four different cars assisted Grant in brutally attacking the girls in exchange for money. The girls were attacked on Angonia Road where they were found and the scene was subsequently staged to resemble a car crash. One witness has reported to Mona's family that they were present for the attack and saw Grant wielding an axe over Mona's head as he said. Where's my money, Julie Smith? Mona replied, I'm not Julie, I'm Mona Lisa. Another witness has claimed to have driven past the crash site the following morning
朱莉和辛迪。赞同这一理论的人认为，几名乘坐四辆不同汽车的原住民男子以金钱为交换，协助格兰特残忍地袭击了这些女孩。女孩们在被发现的安戈尼亚路上遭到袭击，现场随后被伪装成车祸。一名证人向莫娜的家人报告说，他们目击了袭击过程，并看到格兰特挥舞着斧头对准莫娜的头部，并说道：“我的钱在哪儿，朱莉·史密斯？”莫娜回答说：“我不是朱莉，我是蒙娜丽莎。”另一名证人声称，第二天早上
while detectives were at the scene. The witness noticed a man sitting by the side of the road wearing a shirt covered in blood. It has been said that this man later confessed to being present during the attack and claimed he had tried to help Mona. However, police reports contain no mention of any such man being present at the scene. Many years after the girls' deaths, Mona's mother June and sister Fiona visited a male cousin after another family member accused him of being involved in the incident. The two women asked where the cousin had been on the night in question and he replied that he and their auntie had been traveling to Brewerna amongst four car loads of
侦探在现场时，他开车路过了车祸现场。这名证人注意到路边坐着一个穿著血衣的男子。据说这名男子后来承认自己在袭击发生时在场，并声称他曾试图帮助莫娜。然而，警方报告中没有提及现场有任何这样的男子出现。在女孩们去世多年后，莫娜的母亲琼和姐姐菲奥娜拜访了一位男表亲，此前另一位家庭成员指控他卷入了这起事件。这两名女性询问该表亲在出事当晚去了哪里，他回答说他和她们的阿姨正坐着四车人前往布雷韦纳。
people. The cousin's admission to being in a convoy of four vehicles led some to believe he was one of the men who helped Grant attack the two girls. They suspect he merely said he was in Brewerna to cover his tracks and was actually present at the crash site. It has been alleged that the cousin participated in the murders in exchange for money from Grant. For those who believe this alternative theory, it explains why there was so little blood inside the vehicle, how the ute's tyres were inflated and undamaged, why a tarpaulin appeared to have been neatly laid out on the ground and how Grant walked away unharmed. Some of Cindy and Mona's family members are also certain that the girls would never get into a
这位表亲承认自己在一支由四辆车组成的车队中，这让一些人相信他是帮助格兰特袭击两个女孩的男子之一。他们怀疑他只是说自己在布雷韦纳来掩盖行踪，实际上当时就在车祸现场。据称，该表亲参与谋杀是为了换取格兰特的金钱。对于那些相信这一替代理论的人来说，这解释了为什么车内血迹那么少、皮卡轮胎为什么充气且完好无损、为什么地上似乎整齐地铺着防水布、以及为什么格兰特能毫发无伤地离开。辛迪和莫娜的一些家庭成员也确信，除非女孩们认识同行的其他人，否则她们绝不会搭乘陌生白人男子开的车。
vehicle driven by a white stranger unless they knew someone else who was with the driver. Author Richard Stanton, who wrote the book Angonia Road, has proposed another explanation for why Grant might have escaped with so few injuries if he was driving. The theory is that Grant braked suddenly, which led to Mona being thrown through the windscreen. As the vehicle slowed down, Cindy was also thrown from the vehicle. Grant was then tossed sideways into Cindy's now empty seat before the roof was crushed in and he was able to climb out of the now empty windscreen when the vehicle came to a stop. Stanton believes that the car was stanton believes this would also explain how Grant exited the vehicle,
著有《安戈尼亚路》一书的作家理查德·斯坦顿提出了另一种解释，即如果格兰特当时在开车，他为什么能受这么轻的伤就逃脱。这一理论是，格兰特急刹车，导致莫娜从挡风玻璃飞了出去。随着车辆减速，辛迪也被甩出了车外。随后，格兰特被侧向甩到了现在空无一人的辛迪的座位上，接着车顶被压扁，当车辆停下时，他得以从现在空无一人的挡风玻璃爬出去。斯坦顿认为，汽车
as responding officers found that both doors were jammed shut. According to Stanton, after the trial, several experts conceded that this was a plausible scenario. Cindy and Mona's family members are torn as to what exactly happened to the girls on the night of December 5, 1987, with much of their confusion stemming from the fact that they received so little communication from the police. Carrie, Cindy Smith's sister, has criticised investigators for not properly interviewing the Aboriginal community in the immediate aftermath of the girls' deaths, as many had been out in Burke that night and could have provided evidence. In 2018, June Smith told journalist Rosemarie Neal, quote,
斯坦顿认为，这也解释了格兰特是如何离开汽车的，因为出警的警员发现两个车门都卡死了。据斯坦顿称，审判结束后，几位专家承认这是一个合理的假设。对于1987年12月5日晚女孩们究竟遭遇了什么，辛迪和莫娜的家人意见不一，他们的困惑很大程度上源于他们与警方几乎没有沟通这一事实。辛迪的姐姐凯莉批评调查人员在女孩们遇害后没有立即对原住民社区进行适当的采访，因为当晚很多人都在伯克，本可以提供证据。2018年，琼·史密斯告诉记者罗丝玛丽·尼尔：
We didn't know nothing. The police never came and spoke with us. They all sort of kept away. That's the worst part. Sitting and waiting and not knowing. Alexander Grant's defence barrister, Anthony Quinlaven, also spoke with the journalist Rosemarie Neal. Although he maintained that justice was done, he admitted to having some misgivings about the trial's outcome and described it as, One of the most exceptional events that happened to me in 40 years of being a lawyer. As Cindy was 15 years old, Quinlaven queried why the prosecution didn't attempt to prosecute Grant with indecency against a minor instead of indecently interfering with the corpse, quote. Rearranging her clothing, obviously he did that. Blind Freddy could see
“我们什么都不知道。警察从来没有来找我们谈过。他们全都躲得远远的。这才是最糟糕的部分。坐着等待，却一无所知。”格兰特的辩护大律师安东尼·昆利文也接受了记者罗丝玛丽·尼尔的采访。尽管他坚称正义得到了伸张，但他承认对审判结果存有一些疑虑，并将其描述为“在我40年的律师生涯中发生的最非凡的事件之一”。由于辛迪当时只有15岁，昆利文质疑为什么控方没有试图以针对未成年人的猥亵罪起诉格兰特，而不是以“蓄意干扰尸体”罪起诉他：“重新摆放她的衣服，他显然做了那种事。瞎子都看得出来
he must have done that. He was probably doing something despicable at that point. It was difficult to see why it was that the police or the Crown authorities did not work out that they might have had a stronger case if they had charged him with some act of indecency against a minor under the age of 16. The inferences seem very powerful in that regard. Quinlaven acknowledged that his former client had clearly told bare-faced lies throughout his interviews and court proceedings, adding, My fellow was very fortunate to walk away a free man. Rosemarie Neal also contacted the New South Wales police for her article and they supplied the following statement. The case has gone through court proceedings over 30 years ago and police
他一定做过那种事。他当时可能在做一些卑鄙的事情。很难理解为什么警察或王室当局没有意识到，如果他们以对16岁以下未成年人的某种猥亵行为起诉他，他们可能会有更有力的案子。在这方面，推论似乎非常有力。”昆利文承认，他的前当事人在整个审讯和法庭诉讼过程中显然一直在撒谎，并补充说：“我的当事人非常幸运，能大摇大摆地成为一个自由人。”罗丝玛丽·尼尔还联系了新南威尔士州警方以获取她的文章内容，他们提供了以下声明：“此案在30多年前就已经过法院审理，警方
have no further comment on matters that are already on public record. The current relationship between New South Wales police and all members of the Burke and Brewerner communities is cohesive and respectful and continues to develop. In 2017, Alexander Grant died at the age of 70 in Sydney. Prior to his death, he had lived in a nursing home where he required constant care after a stroke had left him with difficulty speaking. Fiona, Mona Smith's sister, told Casefile that she experienced mixed emotions when Grant died because she was deeply saddened that he'd never be brought to justice for Cindy and Mona's deaths. Today, Fiona still lives in Burke and works with local Indigenous youths by teaching them about their ancestors and providing a means for young people
对于已经公开记录的事情，没有进一步的评论。新南威尔士州警方与伯克和布雷韦纳社区的所有成员之间目前的关系是紧密且尊重的，并将继续发展。”2017年，亚历山大·格兰特在悉尼去世，享年70岁。在去世之前，他一直住在一家疗养院里，由于中风导致说话困难，他需要持续的照料。莫娜·史密斯的姐姐菲奥娜告诉《罪案实录》，当格兰特去世时，她百感交集，因为她深感遗憾的是，他永远不会因为辛迪和莫娜的死而被绳之以法。今天，菲奥娜仍然住在伯克，并与当地的原住民青年合作，通过向他们传授祖先的知识，并为年轻人提供
to get involved in their community. She believes that Cindy and Mona's spirits are unable to rest due to the traumatic nature of their deaths. Cindy's mother, Dawn, works for the Burke Aboriginal Legal Service, providing professional and culturally appropriate legal services for Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander people. She says that she doesn't want to die before justice is done. Cindy's sister, Kerry, now lives in Melbourne and believes Cindy's spirit has followed her there as she is unable to rest without justice. Although Grant died in 2017, the girls' families have been petitioning for an inquest into their deaths in the hopes they might finally receive the answers they've sought for more than 30 years. In 2018, Legal Advocacy Group, the National
参与社区活动的方式。她认为，由于死状极其痛苦，辛迪和莫娜的灵魂无法安息。辛迪的母亲道恩在伯克原住民法律服务机构工作，为原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民提供专业且符合文化背景的法律服务。她说，在正义得到伸张之前，她不想死。辛迪的姐姐凯莉现在住在墨尔本，她相信辛迪的灵魂已经跟随她到了那里，因为在正义伸张之前，她无法安息。尽管格兰特于2017年去世，但女孩们的家属一直在请愿对她们的死因进行死因研讯，希望能最终得到他们寻找了30多年的答案。2018年，法律倡导集团“国家
Justice Project, issued a formal complaint about the mishandling of the case to the New South Wales Law Enforcement Conduct Commission. The project's principal solicitor argued that there was evidence Alexander Grant was a sexual predator known for attempting to prey on Aboriginal girls. The statement provided by the girl's cousin Sharon Smith, who said she'd had an encounter with Grant the night before the crash, was cited in the submission. The submission also pointed out that the police failure to retrieve the steering wheel from Grant's vehicle was, quote, fatal to the prosecution charges as they could not prove who was driving. In June 2019, Cindy and Mona's families met with New South Wales police for a formal
司法项目”向新南威尔士州执法行为委员会就该案处理不当提出了正式投诉。该项目的主任律师辩称，有证据表明亚历山大·格兰特是一个性侵犯，以试图对原住民女孩下手而闻名。女孩的表妹莎伦·史密斯在陈述中提到，她在车祸前一天晚上曾与格兰特有过一次遭遇，该陈述被引用到了意见书中。意见书还指出，警方未能从格兰特的车上取回方向盘，这“对控方的指控是致命的，因为他们无法证明当时是谁在开车”。2019年6月，辛迪和莫娜的家属与新南威尔士州警方会面，进行了正式交涉。
mediation session about the case. Fiona Smith told the weekend Australian newspaper that the experience was draining yet positive and she was hopeful they were one step closer to achieving their goals. In an exclusive interview with the weekend Australian, the magistrate who committed Grant to stand trial, Rosemary Kada Smith, also spoke out in favour of an inquest. She described the original investigation as incompetent and labelled Grant's version of events as totally unbelievable lies, quote. I do certainly think some questions should be asked and the matter better exposed. I think this should happen in fairness to the families and the relationship with the Aboriginal community who feel that all interests have not been looked
关于此案的调解会议。菲奥娜·史密斯对《周末澳大利亚人报》表示，这次经历虽然耗费精力但却是积极的，她希望他们距离实现目标又近了一步。在接受《周末澳大利亚人报》的独家采访时，将格兰特交由法院审判的地方法官罗斯玛丽·卡达·史密斯也公开表态支持进行死因研讯。她形容最初的调查是不称职的，并称格兰特对事件的说法是“完全难以置信的谎言”。她原话表示：我确实认为应该提出一些问题，并让事情更好地暴露在阳光下。我认为这样做对家属是公平的，并且对于那些感到并非所有利益都得到关照的土著社区关系来说也是公平的。
after with some reason. In June 2020, Cindy and Mona's families received notice from the deputy director of New South Wales public prosecutions that an inquest was unlikely to go ahead. The decision to drop the charge of indecent interference with Cindy's corpse was defended, though the office of the director of public prosecutions apologised for not notifying Cindy's family of this development prior to the trial. The New South Wales police commissioner had also revealed that two independent inquiries had found the police handling of the case to be adequate. The girls' families were extremely disappointed by these developments, with Fiona Smith telling The Weeknd Australian, quote.
这是有一定理由的。2020年6月，辛迪和莫娜的家属收到新南威尔士州公共检察署副署长的通知，称死因研讯不太可能继续进行。虽然检察署办公室为未能在审判前将这一进展通知辛迪的家属进行了道歉，但撤销对辛迪尸体进行不道德干扰指控的决定仍受到了辩护。新南威尔士州警察局长还透露，两项独立调查发现警方对该案的处理是恰当的。女孩们的家属对这些进展感到极度失望，菲奥娜·史密斯对《周末澳大利亚人报》表示，引用原话。
It's like they're ducking and weaving and no one wants to take responsibility. My mum loses her spark when things like this happen. I saw her sink a bit more. Cindy and Mona's mothers are still fighting for an inquest to be granted. During the making of this episode, they issued an open letter to Casephile that reads, We, the mothers of Cindy and Mona Lisa Smith, want an inquest into our daughter's deaths, which happened on December 6, 1987, on the Angonio Road. It has been 33 years now since we lost them, and nothing has been done to help us find out the truth about what happened to our girls. If they were two white girls, their killers would have been jailed by now,
这就像他们在闪烁其词、逃避责任，没有人愿意承担责任。每当发生这种事，我妈妈就会失去活力。我看到她又消沉了一些。辛迪和莫娜的母亲仍在争取获得死因研讯的机会。在本集制作期间，她们向Casephile发表了一封公开信，内容如下：“我们是辛迪和莫娜·莉萨·史密斯的母亲，我们要求对我们的女儿们的死亡进行死因研讯，她们于1987年12月6日在昂戈尼奥路遇害。自从我们失去她们以来，已经过去33年了，却什么也没有做来帮助我们查明女儿遭遇真相。如果她们是两个白人女孩，她们的凶手现在早就被关进监狱了，”
but they were black girls and everything is swept under the rug. So we ask you, is there one law for white people and a separate law for black people? We have been through a lot these past 33 years, thinking about what happened and whether we will ever get justice for our girls or not. All the stress and pain we are going through now, wondering if we will ever get justice for our daughters. Yours in struggle, Iona Dawn Smith and Edun Smith you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但她们是黑人女孩，一切都被掩盖了。所以我们要问，白人有一套法律，黑人有另一套法律吗？在过去的33年里，我们经历了太多，一直在想发生了什么，以及我们是否能为我们的女儿讨回公道。我们现在经历着所有的压力和痛苦，想知道我们是否能为女儿们讨回公道。与你们共同奋斗的艾奥娜·唐·史密斯和埃敦·史密斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。